well they come guys how you doing we're
back in the car doing chats and cars
with dr. Lawrence Brown how you doing
yeah fine thanks
doing good you get a chance to watch
there was this documentary I don't get
your thoughts on it it's called it's
called I believe expelled no
intelligence allowed have you ever heard
of this documentary what it pretty much
focuses on is that you have within the
university setting you have professors
who usually argue argue for Darwinism
and atheism but then this documentary
goes and points out that there are many
scientists professors who argue for a
creator but their silence
and then how their silence and and and
their blacklist they're pretty much
bullied and it just kind of gives a
different perspective why because
usually you go into this university
setting and then you know the the
students you think wow these are just
academics there everybody is on the same
page that there's no God but no there
there are silence those who usually are
in this atmosphere in this setting
there's silence that's why you don't
hear much about them did you ever hear
this documentary or any what are your
thoughts on this I haven't heard of that
documentary but I have heard of the sort
of the academic bullying the fact that
the fact that professors who are
teaching creationism are basically
shut down and I have the impression
first of all that that's happening less
I mean I have the impression that more
professors are coming out in favor of
intelligent design or in favor of a
creator or in favor of just showing that
evolution just simply doesn't work or
another way of I prefer to just point
out that evolution does not eliminate
the possibility of a creator okay
because because the point is that
evolution natural selection and so on
it might exist it might work but it's
just if it does it's just under the
direction under the control of the
creator
but Sony cuz yeah there's I know this
there's this academic prejudice which is
continuing to persist until this time
sure
have you ever heard of this individual
he was for about fifty years he was a
well-known notorious atheist Anthony
flue he wrote a book recent not too long
ago he went from being a theist to
writing a book there is a God and he was
for fifty years he was out there
preaching that there was no God but he
had an epiphany something happened and
he changed his way the reason I
mentioned him because he was a prettty
moment he was like the Richard Dawkins
of his time called Anthony flew every
heard of him
yeah actually I mean in this circle he
is super famous
I mean he's he was not just you know an
atheist professor he was like the
professor he he was probably the most
famous atheist professor of all of them
during his day and
his
you know his acknowledgement that there
is a crater and that and that evolution
does not does not fully explain our
existence that what that was a shock to
the world of ade ISM yeah and it was
just fascinating fascinating to see how
how many years it took but then he
eventually worked around to that
conclusion and then of course as soon as
he did that you know you know everybody
is like oh he's great he's with us oh
he's wonderful he's with us as soon as
he's switch sides you know they were
denouncing him well this guy doesn't
know what he's talking about you know
how do you go from like being this super
intelligent amazingly amazingly well
informed intelligent professor to you
know to being an outcast
actually actually just to make a point
you know this is this is why I really
talk about the pretensions of science
when it comes to the atheist scientists
because really their decision points are
more emotional than anything else
they're not based on science if they
were based on science they would have
they would have acknowledged the fact
that natural selection and evolution
cannot explain the diversity of life and
the complexity of life as we know it
they would have acknowledged that a long
time ago I mean the biochemical studies
the the probability studies the
statistical issues and so on and so
forth these hard hard hard
you know Sciences where where you can
run the numbers on things like what's
the probability of developing a medium
chain protein to serve as a gene
sequence what's the probability of
having that happen by chance and just
crunching the numbers and finding that
you can't even fit the minimum gene
sequence hypothesis you know or minimum
gene set you have to have a certain
number of genes for an organism to to
function right and if we figure out what
the chance is are
of developing those genes over the
period of existence and the number of
elements in the universe and so on
probability and statistics just just
shows that it's basically impossible and
I'm not impossible but impossible to the
end to you know a huge degree and so
here's where a scientists stopped paying
attention to science it's like I know I
don't like that answer so you know so
we're just we're gonna say but there's
still this tiny tiny tiny tiny
infinitely tiny chance so we'll just say
there's a multiverse to that to that
number of chances and we're the lucky
ones this is not science this is this is
just reverse engineering your own
conclusions and so this is why I say
that you know these guys really they're
just putting on the pretenses of science
but it's not true science what advice do
you have for the University student many
we've heard stories true stories where
the classroom will be full the professor
asked everybody how many of you believe
in God and almost the whole class raised
their hands but towards the end of the
semester after the professor has done
his Dawa and he writes on the board at
in the beginning there's no God here and
then he asked the same question he says
how many of you believe in God now and
at the end
he's probably converted more than 80%
only 2/3 people raise their hand so now
for people getting into that environment
for the student the Muslim students are
just anyone in general what what advice
do you have for them basically you need
to arm yourself with the evidence and
I feel that the strongest argument that
you can make really is just to
acknowledge that the concept of natural
selection the concept of evolution and
the concept of God are not mutually
exclusive in other words there's no
reason why you could not have both if
you're gonna say that natural selection
is operational why can't you say that
this is the mechanism God set into play
to to lead to the diversity of species
why do you have to say okay I can
explain the diversity of life through
naps natural selection so therefore
there is no God no I mean if you have if
you have that belief in God in your
heart just just coming to see a
possibility that natural sexual
selection could be operational should
not should not conflict with that belief
you could just say okay so so yeah so
this is you know this was the mechanism
that our Creator used to to develop the
diversity of life now that's not how I
feel things happened but I'm just saying
that in the defense of a belief and you
know a belief in a creator without
conflict with the concept of natural
selection you have to realize that these
things are not like I said not mutually
exclusive
yeah my wife said that's that's just not
how I feel not how I feel things happen
but that is a way that you can argue the
case so by the way don't be fooled you
give this question to scientists say
where did the light come from don't be
fooled they're gonna say well you know
maybe life was seeded onto this planet
from outer space they're not answering
the question
they're just deferring it okay so where
did it come from came from outer space
and they got it from outer space from
another outer space
well what are we talking about one alien
gave it to another alien gave it to
another alien or your one planet gave it
to another planet to another planet that
does not answer the question where did
it come from in the end
trace it back it had to come from
somewhere right and that's the question
that knows no scientist no group of
scientists have ever been able to answer
the other thing is you know in the in
this discussion yes when you're talking
about evolution again go back before
that stop stop thinking about biological
evolution ask about chemical evolution
chemical evolution there's no acceptable
explanation for it until now and and you
cannot get you cannot even get to
biological evolution until you get over
chemical evolution and that has also
never been explained
guys enjoying some of this important
information I was sharing with you stay
with us
Tom like you said don't let the
professor's bully you
yeah don't let them you know don't let
the professor's bully you don't let them
you know don't let them make you think
that you know because they're a
professor in your student you have to
come to their side that's just
you know that's just ridiculous when it
comes to spiritual arguments you can't
intellectualize spirituality but you
cannot intellectualize spirituality
either have it or you don't
and you don't you can't get a degree in
in spirituality so if you're a believer
hold on to that belief don't let don't
let the professor believe and keep in
mind I mean really keep in mind that
there are well there are professors out
there there are PhDs out there they're
researchers out there in their fields
and more who speak as eloquently or
better in favor of intelligent design in
favor of a creator having recognized
that the arguments for chemical
evolution biological evolution the
presence of life to begin with just
simply are not satisfied by these rather
simplistic what I think are now just
recognized as fallacious formulas such
as evolution such as Darwin's concept of
evolution just real quick Darwin the
many of these arguments in this
philosophy stems off some people don't
know if you can break it down this have
you heard that you know probably's
crystal theory
you mean the idea of life beginning on a
crystal and and when you and you look
into it it's really absurd it's just way
out in there yeah you know and the thing
is that I think that the I think that
these scientists are sort of you know
once you catch them on an explanation
that doesn't work they throw out another
explanation assuming that most people
are not going to research it deeply
enough to realize that that next
explanation they throw out is just BS
okay and and that works for most people
because most people do not investigate
they just hear oh there's another
explanation okay I'll take that
you know because quite frankly most
people are intellectually lazy okay or
they don't have time for it or whatever
but the fact of the matter is that you
have scientists who do devote themselves
to this and and they have basically
proven that these other theories are
just childish and that's why I'm saying
that these people who are arguing
evolution are basically doing so with
the pretensions of pretensions of
science not with real science because
real science is following the evidence
where where it points you you know you
see the evidence pointing in this
direction you go in that direction
you don't just say no I don't like that
conclusion therefore I'm gonna make up
another equally weak explanation for the
theory that I do love that's not science
and you hold on when you know that in
the law hold tight to it la la la la you
know it you understand this unshakable
unshakable